good evening everybody it's a real
pleasure to welcome you to the school
for environmental studies at Yale my
name is David skelly I'm the associate
dean for research and professor of
ecology here in the school and I'll be
moderating the forum this evening I want
to thank first and foremost our fellow
sponsors of tonight's evening the Sierra
Club I would also like to thank the Yale
climate and energy institute and you
know without without their support this
wouldn't have been possible i also want
to thank senator Blumenthal and his
staff for making this evening happening
I want to start off by introducing the
organizer from the Sierra Club on ty
Johnson who's going to say a few words
and then I'll be back up to give the the
rules for the evening thank you thank
you very much for coming out tonight my
name is anti Johnson and I'm the
organizer for the Sierra Club and
tonight's discussion will be focused on
climate change for those of you that do
not know the Sierra Club is the world's
largest and oldest environmental
organization we've dedicated the past
121 years for trying to protect the
environment raising awareness so that we
can breathe clean air and we can help
combat against climate change the past
four years the next four years in
President Obama's election will be very
pivotal on how we combat against climate
change we have seen devastating droughts
floods raging wildfires and here in
Connecticut we've been impacted by
hurricanes Irene and Sandy just a couple
of months ago we had a huge snowstorm
Nemo and this is affecting our economy
and it's affecting our families so we've
are calling on our
leaders to see what can we do to help
this issue so we've put together this
town hall and we want to thank senator
Blumenthal because he's been a leader
when he was an attorney general with the
environment and he can help President
Obama with his climate legacy we have
professor Nadine hunger and we have
Anthony Liza wits who is the director of
the Yale project on climate change
communication so we hope that everybody
would have a very good time we will have
a chance to answer questions and ask
questions to everyone here and I hope
that this will be a great opportunity
for you guys to learn about the
environment because this is real thank
you very much thank you auntie and I'm
going to join our day and thanking
everyone all three of our panelists who
are going to help us through the this
evening to talk about a really important
topic what we're going to do is ask each
of our participants starting with
senator Blumenthal to speak for about
five to seven minutes on the overall
issue of climate change and when each of
them has had a chance to speak senator
Blumenthal then professor hunger and
then professor zarowitz then we're going
to turn it over to questions from you
that came in in in advance that we've
collated and we'll use that as a basis
for a conversation among all these three
folks and then during the the
presentation period if you would like to
write down additional questions there
are folks with baskets spread out spread
throughout the room they can kind of
raise their hands right there there you
go if you would like to write down a
question and pass it along we're going
to do our utmost to grab some questions
from the floor that kind of kind of
reflect what's what's going on in the
room here the last opportunity to do
that it's going to be at the end of the
the third presentation so we have time
to kind of kool-aid those and neaten up
hand right
and so on so with that I'm going to ask
this participants are going to speak
from where they're sitting there I'm
going to ask each of them to spend five
to seven minutes talking about climate
change and how they view it from there
their disparate perspectives Cyril
thought we wanted to speak from here
yeah if you don't mind babe well first
of all let me add my thanks to the
Sierra Club for having us here this
evening Thank You Dante and to all the
members were here all of the leaders but
also for their championing the
environment over many years during many
fights in Long Island's found in the
hills of Litchfield in the farmington
valley i can go fight by fight by fight
but you have been there and i've been
very proud to work with you and advocate
with you for a cleaner environment for
preserving what really makes connecticut
so special what makes our planet so
special which is the natural resources
that we want to leave for our children
and let me sort of begin where they left
his part of the discussion we have seen
over the last year to two years the
indisputable effects of climate change
in causing financial and human disasters
here in Connecticut we've seen
hurricanes super storms snow falls that
are unmatched for their ferocity and
their impact on our way of life as well
as on people's livelihoods and lives so
there's a lesson here which even the
climate change deniers have trouble
refuting which is that our world is
changing and we have a window of
opportunity to do something about it
isn't it isn't an opportunity that will
last forever
and somebody may not have liked what I
was saying not for the first time and I
really don't necessarily need this
because I think you all can hear me we
have it we have a window of opportunity
a practical window of opportunity to do
something about it I want to speak for a
moment about the political window of
opportunity which is as real and
important as the scientific or natural
opportunity and that window of
opportunity is created by the presidency
of Barack Obama number one the
Democratic majority in the Senate number
two and I think we need to seize this
moment to try to push forward as quickly
and forcefully as possible with measures
that are achievable there were some
votes in the final hours of the Senate
before it adjourned for the recess that
we're discouraging there's no other way
to put it there was an amendment that
essentially would have resulted in
approval of Keystone pipeline it was
approved by more than 60 votes in the
Senate it was offered by Senator Hoeven
and there was a vote on an amendment
relating to an anti carbon tax offered
by Senator Whitehouse it failed those
were just symbolic votes but they
reflect that we have a battle ahead if
we want to make progress on climate
change the good news is I think the
American people get it on a variety of
issues I've only been in the Senate for
two years I've seen that a minority can
stymie the will of what seems to be the
majority of American people we're seeing
it at present on another seemingly
unrelated issue gun violence there
in a number of others that that I've
seen while I've been in the Senate but i
think it is only a matter of organizing
and galvanizing opinion the majority of
americans feel that we can and must do
something about climate change and i'd
be happy to take questions but let me
just finish with what i think is one of
the major lessons that we need to import
and it's sort of on this on this mug
business and the environment Yale Center
for business and the environment one of
the major messages that I tried to
impart well I was attorney general I've
tried to do it in this off as well as
that economic growth and jobs are not in
conflict with environmental values when
we fought broadwater which was as you'll
recall the natural gas facility that a
number of major corporations wanted to
put in the middle of Long Island Sound
in my view the fight was not
environmental preservation Long Island
Sound vs natural gas jobs and business
it was in fact how do we protect a
resource that provides billions of
dollars in revenue through its use from
recreation navigation and so forth
against a force that would undermine
that economic value and similarly the
destruction of Long Island Sound would
be an immense loss financially and
economically for both Connecticut and
New York in every one of those
environmental fights I think the case
could be made that we actually get
better in terms of economic growth and
business in the long run by preserving
and enhancing the environment same is
true on climate change ultimately we
will pay much much more if we have to go
through these continuing 100-year storms
you know each of these storms is
something that the insurance company say
happens only every hundred years well
the hundred year storm is now becoming
the one year storm the new normal and we
are having to build new physical
infrastructure and we are losing
shoreline literally in the last year or
two as a result of the storms that we've
seen already which are just a harbinger
of what is to come so I think we need to
make the case that economic growth and
jobs are not only compatible with
preventing climate change from
continuing but also are well served in
fact enhanced by the effort to stop the
kinds of causes of carpet of climate
change that we know can be addressed
carbon emissions the whole I mean for
this audience I don't need to spell it
out but these these measures are within
our reach they are feasible and doable
and we need to begin them thank
so thank you senator Blumenthal now
we'll hear from Professor Nadine younger
Thank You senator Blumenthal ladies and
gentlemen the industrial revolution that
began in the United Kingdom over 200
years ago and rapidly spread throughout
the rest of the world is undoubtedly one
of the most important events in the
history of humanity our ability to
unleash vast amounts of energy from
fossil fuels has led to great social and
economic benefits but also to the two
most dire environmental problems of our
time the global spread of air pollution
and global climate change so I want to
make very clear up front here that
Earth's climate system is dynamic for
example 55 million years ago the earth
system was so hot that crocodiles lived
in the Arctic and Antarctica was a pine
forest if we go back even further in
time 650 million years ago the earth may
have been a frozen snowball with ice
sheets extending all the way down to the
equator we do know that over the past 1
million years the Earth's climate system
has been oscillating regularly between
cool glacial and warmer interglacial
periods about every hundred thousand
years and in fact in the last glacial
period about 20,000 years ago there was
a mile thick sheet of ice right above
where we are all sitting now so planet
earth experiences massive natural shifts
in climate that a call
caused primarily by changes in Earth's
orbit that are then amplified by
feedbacks in greenhouse gases and the
surface ice coverage that changes the
color of the Earth's surface so in this
way nature maintains itself a delicate
balance of greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere through a perfectly tuned
perfectly aligned system of
biogeochemical cycles in the time span
of one human lifetime in the great
acceleration over the last half-century
we have drastically altered these
natural cycles we have changed the
atmospheric carbon dioxide concentration
so it is now thirty percent higher than
pre-industrial levels atmospheric
methane concentrations are more than
double pre-industrial levels we have
loaded the atmosphere with toxic aerosol
particulates that have very complex
impacts on climate sulfates organics and
black carbon and also kill about 1
million people every year we have also
introduced into the earth system
entirely man-made halo carbon molecules
CFCs HCFCs and HCFCs these molecules do
not occur in nature some of them have
global warming potentials in the
thousands and others have ripped a hole
in the stratospheric ozone layer the
Industrial Revolution goes hand in hand
with the Agricultural Revolution and we
do know that the cropland expansion
alone has modified fifty percent of
Earth's ice free land surface half of
the lands
this never before have such changes in
such a short time frame being
experienced by planet Earth so it is
critical to recognize that the physics
of climate change is not controversial
in any way this science is clear it's
well understood it's well accepted and
it has been for the past 150 years it is
exactly like the unsinkable titanic if
we smash a great big hole in the side of
the titanic that unsinkable ship will
sink similarly if we continue to load
the atmosphere with long wave absorbing
greenhouse gases the earth's surface
will warm it really is that simple what
is more uncertain and the cause of the
scientific debate are the feedbacks in
the Earth's system that can act to
amplify or dampen the climate response
to the anthropogenic forcing even as we
speak the international scientific
community is working very hard to
understand better to improve our
understanding of these feedbacks some
relatively good news is that in 2010 the
Cancun accord did reach a consensus that
global warming since the pre-industrial
must be kept below two degrees C Celsius
and in the following year in 2011 the
United Nations Environment Programme
released an assessment report showing
clearly and unequivocally that the only
possible way to achieve this target is
through immediate and simultaneous
reductions in carbon dioxide and the
short-lived
climate warmers methane tropospheric
ozone and black carbon aerosol so now
that we're onto the subject of aerosol
particulates air pollution particles a
formidable obstacle that we face is that
the cooling short-lived climate forcers
the cooling air pollutants sulfate and
organic particles are currently masking
fifty percent of the committed
greenhouse gas warming due to the
Industrial Revolution that's huge half
of the warming is being masked James
Hansen calls this masking effect
humanity's Faustian climate bargain in
that we have been enjoying the benefits
of the Industrial Revolution without too
much of a cost to climate yet but
payment is coming to you because air
pollution has now reached intolerable
levels and must be reduced to protect
ecosystems and human health the
implication is that air quality control
legislation must be implemented with
great care to avoid pushing the system
passed a tipping point and inducing a
rapid warming surge that is unsafe for
humans and ecosystems the truth is that
air quality control legislation is
usually implemented without any
consideration of the effects on climate
here awaits a unique opportunity for
this generation of environmental
managers to develop win-win energy
policy and mitigation strategies that
are beneficial to both climate and air
quality and in so doing maintain a safe
operating space for human
t-thank you
so thank you Nadine for that chirpy
synopsis and now we're going to move on
to Tony low zarowitz great thank you
Dave and first of all let me say thank
you to the Yale School of Forestry
environmental studies yce I and the
Sierra Club for hosting this event it's
really exciting to see this many people
come out to have this conversation and I
really want to underscore that key theme
starting the conversation or another way
of putting it is ending the silence so i
thought i was going to take us back in
the history and then I heard we went
back 650 million years so I don't feel
so bad I want to take you back just a
couple years to 2006 2007 because I want
to talk about the grand arc of what's
been happening with public opinion so
that's what I study is a large-scale
public opinion on climate change how do
people respond to this issue why don't
they respond to this issue back in two
thousand five six and seven we saw
public opinion swelling up surging up
and reaching what we could call a
high-water mark and what was unique
about that is that this was in the
context and this is one of our oldest
most important findings all along is
that many Americans think of climate
change as a distant problem distant in
time that the impacts won't be felt for
a generation or more and distant in
space this is about polar bears maybe
some small island countries developing
countries not the United States not
Connecticut not New Haven not my friends
and family or the people in places that
I care about okay so it was one of those
issues that was out there maybe we'll
deal with it some day but it wasn't seen
as urgent or pressing but public opinion
started to swell in two thousand five
and six and seven and what was
interesting is that that was almost
entirely a media-driven engagement for
Americans let me take you back that was
the Bush era this was the era of
inconvenient truth the IPCC report the
Academy Awards the Nobel Peace Prize for
both al gore and the IPCC Arnold
Schwarzenegger passing climate change
legislation in California
the Bush administration hey all of those
were widely reported in the media and
that's how most Americans engage with
this issue because guess what Americans
don't read the peer-reviewed literature
they don't read reports they don't know
climate scientists personally okay they
know about this through predominantly
the media but then a funny thing
happened and that was the year 2008 and
among many things that began to happen
was the economic collapse the financial
crisis and surging unemployment and we
saw that public responses and engagement
with climate change drop pretty
dramatically a 14 percentage point drop
in Americans even belief that climate
change is happening drops in that is
human caused drops in levels of worry
and concern about the issue and there
were a lot of things going on there not
just the economic crisis another big one
was that the media stopped reporting
this issue newspaper coverage dropped by
about two-thirds nightly network news
coverage like the CBS Evening News NBC
nightly news etc drop ninety percent
okay now this is an issue that all of us
can look out these windows if only we
could and there's co2 pouring out of
tailpipes it's pouring out of buildings
it's pouring out of smokestacks in fact
it's pouring out of each of us right
this very second and yet none of us can
see it it's invisible okay and likewise
the impacts are invisible unless you
know where to look so when the media
doesn't report this issue it's literally
out of sight and out of mind for most
Americans okay and so this bottom doubt
in 2010 okay pretty substantial drop and
lots of other things happen in that time
period as well but since 2010 public
opinion has started to pick back up
again okay and it is surged it's not
quite back up to where we were in 2007
but it's getting pretty close and
there's something however that's
qualitatively different about this
moment in the trajectory of this issue
than where we were the last time we saw
that way beginning to crest again back
in two thousand five six and seven that
was predominantly through media stories
ok and again within the context that
this was a distant problem
this time is different because as the
senator alluded to just a few minutes
ago two thousand eleven and two thousand
twelve were all time record setting
extreme weather years okay one extreme
event after another after another after
another and what people have begun to do
actively themselves without waiting for
scientist without waiting for the media
to tell them are actively interpreting
this emerging pattern it's an old saying
if something happens once it happens
dance if it happens twice then it's
coincidence if it happens three times
you're beginning to see a pattern
happens 4 5 6 7 8 22 record-setting
events x 22 billion dollar disaster
times in the course of two years many
Americans are beginning to connect those
dots and in fact in our survey research
we show that 8 out of 10 Americans say
that they have personally experienced
one or more of those natural disasters a
Thursday that they have either been
personally or financially harmed by one
of those events and they are
increasingly now a large majorities
upwards of seventy percent believe that
climate change is making many of these
fires floods droughts storms worse okay
so there's something fundamentally
different in the way that Americans are
engaging with this issue at this moment
okay and as I said it is beginning to
swell it it's beginning to surge again
so we are beginning to talk about it
again but let me just come back to that
key underscored point we have been
largely silent not talking about climate
change for the past two years our
political leaders have been silent many
environmental groups have been kind of
quiet the media has been very quiet okay
and Americans themselves have not been
talking about this issue that has begun
to change okay and I think that's what's
really interesting about this moment
because the President himself called for
this in his inaugural as well as in his
follow-up State of the Union address is
for Americans to start talking about
this is
you okay and I think this gathering
tonight is the beginning of what should
be happening all over the country
conversations in communities all across
this country about what does climate
change mean to us not to the distant
future not just to polar bears and
faraway places but what does it mean to
us in our communities for the people and
the places that we love and cherish okay
this is the beginning of a new
conversation thank you
so thanks to all three of our
participants for kicking this off so
well I want to just remind everyone if
you want to hand in a question now's
your kind of last moment to do that I'm
gonna ask the first question of the
panelist that I'm going to sit down and
join them and we're going to get into
the conversation here and I want to
build off something that song was era
what's was just talking about so these
these are all questions that came from
folks in the public what do you say to
the sizable fraction of Americans who do
not believe that the climate is changing
or who do not believe there is human
agency in those changes and I guess what
I would tag on to that is something that
Tony was saying and that is when we have
these recent patterns of weather events
that seem to support the idea of a
changing climate it seems like public
response is is there but the same thing
happens when we go for a long time
between storms or between severe events
so maybe senator Blumenthal can kick us
off on this well I think that that
question is excellent something I deal
with literally every day at a lot of
different levels some with public
officials some with folks on the street
I don't think that the obstacle is so
much whether there is such a thing as
climate change I think that Tony really
hit the key point it's a question of
when it is a reality for us in other
words people have a sense yeah things
are changing but they kind of feel well
later this century you know it's
something my grandchildren will have to
worry about a lot of people care about
the world that their grandchildren will
inherit but it's not something that they
get up in the morning and worry about
while they're shaving or eating
breakfast and certainly not something
they think about when they're out of
work or when they're feeling they may be
out of work the country over these last
few years has been seized with a real
anxiety and apprehension about the
future of the American economy and
rightly so
because we are really failing to train
young people for the jobs that will be
there in just a few years from now there
are openings now for people who do not
who can't fill those jobs because they
don't have the right skills
environmental science and this great
school is training people for jobs that
have to do with saving our planet and
automation that will make manufacturing
cleaner and technology that can help us
do the kinds of things we need to do to
avoid climate change there are again I
said it earlier economic opportunities
here that we have to seize so in answer
to your question I would say to people
it's coming you know it's coming but
it's sooner than you think and just look
around I want to add one piece of good
news here and I really should have
mentioned it probably earlier you know
when we talk about what do the majority
of Americans feel I think we are dealing
with a lot of different audiences and
tony is also right that this
conversation can be led by people in
this room you know the country responds
to individuals reaching out to them
leading by example and look at how the
world has changed in certain ways you
know use of seat belts and so forth but
one of our main audiences is one person
the president of United States he has
committed himself unequivocally in the
State of the Union and in the inaugural
to make this issue one of his priorities
and he has the legal authority to do it
the epa has the authority to promulgate
greenhouse gas emission rules they may
be challenged by industry eventually
they probably will be but he can lead
and his new EPA commissioner can lead by
promulgating those rules and
making sure that they are defended
vigorously so supporting the president
is one of the things that audience that
you can do and he in turn I think can
also change minds you know never
underestimate the power of the President
to use that bully pulpit to change
public opinion and also you know it just
comes to me one of I'm sure I'm going to
mangle this quote but Margaret Meads
famous line about never underestimate
the ability of a small number of
intelligent committed people to change
the world it's the only thing that ever
has so you can do it so I'd like to
address the this issue about you know
what do we say to that fraction of the
American public who don't believe the
climate change is happening or
human-caused and I think it's actually a
very serious question because the fact
is that our politics are caught right
now still in this first level of
discussion is it even real is it human
cause is it serious and first of all I
want to do something about saying let's
stop first of all recognize it or first
recognize that the American public
doesn't speak with a single voice of
this issue and in our own work we've
identified what we call global warming
six America's six different audiences
within the United States they each
respond to this issue in very different
ways and I won't go through them off one
at one end is the alarmed these are
people who think it's happening
human-caused is an urgent problem and
they want to take action but they don't
know what that action is and that's an
important audience to communicate with
what are those solutions both
individually and collectively but at the
other end of the spectrum we have two
groups we call the doubtful and the
dismissive the doubtful who think it's
not probably happening but if it is it's
natural nothing we can do anything about
and then the dismissive who think no
it's not happening and it's not human
caused and many of them think it's a
hoax okay now first of all
it's important to recognize there are
all those different views but secondly
those two groups are relatively small
the doubtful in our last study as of
just last September are thirteen percent
the dismissive are eight percent eight
percent and yet there are really vocal
eight percent okay they're pretty
organized eight percent there ain't a
percent that is well represented in the
Senate not this one I I know them well
but some of your colleagues so we can't
ignore them and so I wanted to say a
couple things about these communities
first of all is to recognize that they
are motivated by fear just like many of
the alarmed are motivated by fear the
alarmed are afraid of climate change
they're afraid of all these impacts that
we've just been discussing okay but the
dismissive are also afraid because what
they're afraid of is the policy response
what they're afraid of is that to deal
with climate change or that that really
climate change is an excuse to make the
government bigger to make it more
intrusive to increase taxes to increase
government regulation to take away
Americans liberties okay that's their
fear okay at least for many of them okay
that's powerful and we have to recognize
that it's not just ignorance it's not
willfully saying I don't believe the
science okay there are reasons why they
don't believe the science and a lot of
it has to do with their concerns that
this issue is going to require
fundamental changes in the relationship
between government and society in that
sense climate change is just another
front in a much bigger war in this
country over what is the proper role of
government okay they also distrust the
traditional messengers okay they don't
trust environmentalists they certainly
don't trust al gore and they don't
really trust barack obama fact they
really don't trust it barack obama okay
so yes the president can stand up and
use his bully pulpit to engage with the
majority of americans but by his very
act
doing so he's going to create a backlash
among those who don't trust him and we
have to recognize that so I just like to
finish this point by saying recognize as
well that there are many different roads
to Damascus people can come to engage
with the issue of climate change and the
solutions to climate change from many
different directions some people are
going to engage with this issue based on
their religious values other because of
the economic opportunities and their
enormous economic opportunities in the
clean energy future some are going to
engage because of the national security
threats others on the health impacts
okay and some may even start to engage
around their core issue of freedom
because if you're a rancher in Texas or
a farmer in Oklahoma it's not the
government that's taking away your
livelihood it's not the government
that's taking away your freedom of
choice to live your life the way you
want to get to drop okay and you can't
appeal to anybody on that okay so in the
end that's one of the places I'd like to
bring us back to is that yes this issue
continues to be politically polarizing
but ultimately the climate system
doesn't care climate system doesn't care
whether you're a Democrat or a
Republican I let check me if the models
say anything different doesn't care if
you're a liberal or conservative ok sir
hurricane sandy did not distinguish
between democratic households and
republican ones the drought doesn't just
take out liberal ranchers and not
conservative ones so we have to move
that part of the discussion is it real
is it human caused is it serious out of
this politics and then let's have a
really robust political debate about
what the best solutions are
so I want to do you want to say
something Nadine yes I would like to
make one brief extended comment on this
yeah it will be briefed on this question
which is that in fact Americans who who
don't believe that climate change is
happening in in somewhere quite smart so
if we because if we I want us to move
away from extreme events and think about
global warming and issues of scale so
the global warming signal is point 7
Kelvin that's attributed to human
activities unequivocally over the last
century and what humans experience what
we experienced is local weather
fluctuations that are five to ten times
larger than that signal so we can't
detect global warming signal in our
local experience in our daily lives the
the tragic problem the very difficult
problem is that if we wait until the
global warming signal becomes large
enough for us to detect in our daily
weather fluctuation experience then
we're on a completely different planet
to the one in which civilization
developed we're in a world without a
Himalayan glacier without a Greenland
ice sheet with no chance of growing food
in the bread basket in the US that's the
challenge so can I have a conversation
about that oh sure because actually I
don't think it's quite that bleak I mean
I agree with you in the end we have to
have science to help us understand the
real implications and consequences of
what we're doing no question however our
own research different published shows
that actually people do have the
capability of detecting even the subtle
changes in temperature and precipitation
in their local experience and then the
other key thing is that it you know
climate manifest
through extreme events and that is
something that we absolutely do detect
and can respond to so I haven't given up
on human beings ability to respond to
this issue yet and it reminds me of the
old saying you know it's the equivalent
to the boiling frog analogy right that
if you put a frog into a pot of water
that's boiling it'll immediately jump
out if you put it into a pot of water
this room temperature and you slowly
turn out the temperature it will not
notice the temperature change and it
will croak turns out and Dave correct me
if I'm wrong that's not actually true
that frogs are actually very exquisitely
sensitive li2 into their environment and
when it gets too hot they jump the hell
out of the pot okay and in fact you know
what this is to you ever put your hand
in under uh under the kitchen sink and
turn on the hot water and it gets hotter
and hotter and eventually it gets too
hot and you pull your hand out that's
the exact same thing that frogs can do
too so I think the question isn't are we
smarter than frogs the question is are
we as smart as frogs and we thought the
Frog story though is too good to give up
I don't wanna so Tony just betrayed
himself because he just said that people
don't read the peer-reviewed literature
and evidently he has read some of my
work on thermal preference behavior and
larval amphibians so let's move on to
another topic as fascinating as the
frogs are the natural gas boom and
fracking are rapidly changing the energy
picture in the United States is this
ultimately going to be a positive or
negative development for those worried
about climate change you want to go in
order you know I really want to lodge a
formal complaint that I'm always the
first to answer no I I'm just kidding
I'm just kidding but these these
responses are so great I
feel I'm I'm learning I hope you are
from what my colleagues here are saying
you know I think number one I think
fracking obviously has gray perils
safeguards are necessary but the
potential for more natural gas i think
is a real opportunity but what we really
need in this country is an energy policy
that incentivize and drives renewables
of all kinds solar thermal you know wind
fuel cells the state of connecticut is
the fuel cell capital of the country we
make fuel cells here in greater number
than anywhere else we could be the fuel
cell capital world again another way
environmental protection smart energy
policy can be an economic boon if we
just had an energy policy that favored
tax credits you know I I spend time with
the fuel cell producers of Connecticut
and the United States and other
countries are encouraging manufacturing
of fuel cells we need to look beyond
fracking to those sources of energy
renewable energy clean energy that can
not only benefit us in terms of the
environment going forward but can offer
even greater opportunities than new
sources of natural gas as good as they
may be because now natural gas is
cleaner but other sources where we can
lead the world and lead by example
that's what the United States can do is
lead by example yes so the in terms of
natural gas and fracking the latest
climate science is clear on that natural
gas is not any better for climate than
coal it is better for air quality but
not for global warming a serious problem
with natural gas
is leakage of methane and there is a
serious lack of measurements of methane
emissions and volatile organic carbon
emissions from fracking sites and
natural gas extraction sites in the u.s.
in fact this industry has grown so
rapidly that these emissions are not
even included in the US EPA national
emissions inventory they're not on the
map so we certainly need to have a more
extensive measurement campaign before we
can say anything more more definitive
about natural gas in the United States
well I'll just very quickly say yeah I'm
going to channel my colleague Jim stairs
we had a whole panel on this fascinating
pedal on this last year and you know he
was very clear that the science is still
very new about the ultimate consequences
of this rush into fracking and into
natural gas yes when you burn it in a
power plant it produces half the co2 of
coal and that's important however when
you do a full life cycle analysis from
the well all the way through the pipes
through the distribution system and into
that plant it's not clear yet we
actually just don't know and yet we're
rushing into this boom without having
that scientific basis of knowledge and
that's of course of concern to those of
us in the scientific community so we
don't really know yet and we don't know
how solvable that is you know even if we
do find that the wells leak or that the
pipes leak and so on are those fixable
or is there something fundamentally
wrong the other is of course this is a
huge question of trade-offs coal is an
old and dirty and polluting and terrible
energy source for health reasons like
she was just saying all kinds of reasons
and yet
you know natural gas does burn cleaner
it's better for health it's maybe better
for climate change too okay and it's a
lot cheaper okay I mean I'm just saying
we don't fully know and there are these
all these other trade-offs you know the
communities that have to endure the
fracking boom it's an incredible
transformation of the local landscape
the local soundscape the local smell
scape and everything else and I think
the one other concern that I think many
people would point to is that this
incredible new energy source which is
American it's not imported however it
has been so cheap that is making it
harder for renewables to compete that
it's actually making it harder to put
the fine or to have the market
incentives for solar and wind and
geothermal and all the other things that
we know are much cleaner so I think we
just have to recognize that this is one
of those situations where yes people
have very cleared great very clear bad
and then I think many at least of us in
the scientific community are really
uncertain maybe we can build on that and
and i'll start with nadine this time so
Nadine you've expressed some skepticism
about gas so what what does a realistic
climate friendly energy portfolio look
like can renewables do it alone should
we be talking about nuclear step right
in there thank you so there is a very
provocative study or initiative coming
out of Stanford University led by marc
jacobson that is a very clear well a
well-developed plan to power the world's
energy needs using wind water and solar
no nuclear and it's very convincing
and Mark has produced several technical
and papers showing that this this way
forward is is feasible economically also
and this group's argument is the main
limitation is actually political will so
at this point I'm going to pass it over
to Senator I'm not cheering for that one
well said you know let's let's step back
for a moment the American economy is at
a critical turning point and even if you
feel relatively secure about it I can
tell you that tens of millions of
Americans do not and I don't know what
your polling shows but you know I've
been talking a lot about gun violence
immigration reform climate change
overwhelmingly the American people want
to know that they will have jobs and
that we will have economic growth so you
know when you're talking about reaching
audiences which you have to do if you're
talking about convincing those six
groups think about beginning from some
common ground that we all have a stake
in climate change not just because it's
the right thing to do or because there's
a science that shows that will have more
of these hundred year storms and but
that we can create jobs by doing it and
that were not against jobs simply by
favoring renewables or a net or an
energy policy that compensates for as
was rightly pointed out that cheapness
inexpensive pneus of natural gas versus
those renewables to do what Nadine has
described and I don't know about this
particular plan but
there are lots of them you know wind
water solar great how do you make it
work economically and how do you make it
work tomorrow and how do you convince
Americans that it won't deprive them of
jobs senator Inhofe offered an amendment
to block greenhouse gas rules
promulgated by the EPA the EPA as you
know is promulgating I refer to them
earlier these carbon emissions standards
for new coal-fired plants new ones not
even dealing with existing ones he
offered an amendment to block it it got
47 votes in the Senate both Republican
and Democrat now that's not because
people want climate change it's because
of the apprehension that it will be
detrimental economically and I think
that's what we really need to address in
any of these plans that maximize the
importance of renewables and they are
realistic on you know nothing I've said
should be understood we're misunderstood
to say oh will their pie in the sky
their unachievable but to move them
forward we need to deal with Americans
where they live which is getting up in
the morning and going to work having a
job feeling sure they can put their kids
through school that they will be secure
in their retirements these are real life
and and I know many of you in this room
already know this I I apologize for
telling you something you already know
but I can't emphasize too strongly the
importance of the economy and jobs so
and I hate to you know I don't mean to
be the pessimist or the naysayer here
but I think it's something we need to
deal with in that conversation that Tony
says very rightly we need to have let's
push in on that a little bit I'm going
to combine a question that came in
before the event with one that came from
the audience here question before the
event was
basically asking what's the role of
market-based mechanisms to make this
happen and a question from the floor is
do do basically do we need cap and trade
or a carbon tax to make it happen so
what is going to be the way forward to
get Americans on board something like
this well I'll actually combine my
answer a little bit with the previous
one and actually goes back to a
wonderful quote from Bill McKibben and
it actually is recognizing the scale of
the problem that we have okay it's not
just the scale the climate change
problem it's that this is about our
energy system as Nadine quite rightly
pointed out an energy system that has
given us all of this it's in our clothes
it's in the food we eat it's in the way
we get around and the buildings were in
everything it's fossil fuels and Bill
McKibben's wonderful quote is that we
need to resist the temptation to look
for silver bullets what we need is
silver buckshot okay we know we're going
to need a lot of different approaches
there is no one thing that's going to
solve this solar can't do this by itself
wind cannot do this by itself nuclear
cannot do this by itself okay and in
fact there are a whole range of things
that we need to do which also include
forestry and conservation as a matter of
fact but also and I just like to put my
emphasis here on energy efficiency and
conservation as one of those key things
and in fact it's one of those key things
that you can get both Democrats and
Republicans to agree about those
dismissive sigh talked about before the
people don't think losing climate
changes a hoax they conserve energy as
much as anybody else in America okay not
because they care about climate change
but because they don't like wasting
things first of all okay and secondly
they certainly don't like wasting money
and the fact is is that this country is
not the leaf world's leader when it
comes to energy efficiency we're way
down the list of other developed
countries okay we are throwing money
literally out the window every day okay
and that's not good for our economy that
not good for our jobs that's not good
for the environment so there's actually
a big slice of this problem that we
could solve with an aggressive effort to
improve our energy efficiency in our
homes through insulation through more
fuel-efficient vehicles through lighting
through air conditioning water heating
etc I mean this building itself is a
testament to the effort to try to become
more energy efficient I think there's
actually tremendous economic opportunity
in no small part 4 retro fits with our
existing stock here in New England which
I mean talk about an inefficient
infrastructure I'm living in a house
that was built in nineteen twelve and I
can tell you it is not efficient there's
so much we can do but the great thing
about those retrofits is that those jobs
cannot be out sourced okay those are
going to require Americans coming into
every building in America and making an
energy efficient you cannot send that
job to the Chinese okay so that's at
least one of the places where I would
hope that the two parties could actually
come together and say look we have
shared American values here of waste not
want not to the other question about
market mechanisms well this comes to the
question of comprehensive climate action
and I personally don't see that
happening because yes we have President
Obama in the White House who wants to
take action yes we have a majority in
the Senate who perhaps want to take
action we also have a House of
Representatives that is run by the other
party which right now many of them
dispute the climate change is a serious
problem so I don't yet see how we get
that comprehensive solution out of
Washington DC which by no means means
that we have to just stop and wait
because there's a tremendous amount of
good things that can be done at the
state level and at the city level and so
on incredible amount of good stuff but
in the end it seems to me those
market-based mechanisms are one of the
ways hopefully we can bring Republicans
back to the table because I think
perhaps and this was something President
Obama said in a state of the union
address he he
John McCain and the efforts to pass a
market-based cap-and-trade system first
sponsored again and again by John McCain
former presidential candidate for the
republican party and said but if you
won't use a market-based mechanism
you're going to force me to use the EPA
and to regulate okay so that is
hopefully the reaching out and the stick
okay because everybody recognizes that
EPA regulation is not the most
economically efficient way to solve this
issue so perhaps politically the other
those doubtful and dismissive of this
issue will come back to this and say
look we want to solve this problem but
we want to do it with our free market
principles which one of which was
cap-and-trade carbon tax might be
another cap and dividend is yet another
form of that that basic approach but
will the politics support it so I have
one more question I want to make sure we
get in before I invite a ante back up to
the podium I think a couple of you
touched on the fact that climate change
can feel like this distant thing and it
can also feel very disempowering to
people to figure out what they can do
and so what I want to finish up doing is
combining again a question that was sent
in to us ahead of time with one that
came from from the floor the question
from before hand was what can we do here
in Connecticut that can make a
difference for a global issue like
climate change as Nadine emphasized and
add on to that there was a question from
the floor about the Bridgeport harbour
power station and should we close it is
that one of the things that we can do so
who wants to step in so what can we do
here well what we can do as a community
here in Connecticut I would support
driving less don't drive unnecessarily
don't use our cars unnecessarily for
long trips don't drive with one person
only in a car use public transport
wherever possible I was involved in a
scientific study that showed clearly
that on road transportation is the most
warming sector on short time scales and
is unambiguously warming on short and
long timescales so anything we can do to
reduce road vehicle emissions as a
community is doing something for global
climate change well I'll go second and
let the sender have the last word so I
think there's a number of things that we
could do here in Connecticut I mean
certainly at the institutional or
governmental level and I think the
center already alluded to them we are
one of the world's leaders in the clean
energy economy we should invest in that
we should invest in that big time we
should invest in clean energy okay
Connecticut already pays some of the
highest electricity prices in the world
okay we all and i will speak personally
here i want solar panels on my roof
because i have been ten days without
power after Hurricane Irene and then
came superstorm sandy and then came
snowstorm Nemo I'm starting to feel like
climate change has something personal
for me because i live in Hamden
Connecticut we got 40 inches of snow I
think we could strengthen Reggie the
Regional Greenhouse Gas Initiative of
which Connecticut was a pioneering
leading member our own regional
cap-and-trade system I don't know enough
about this but Connecticut is one of the
world's capitals of the insurance
industry what are we doing here in
Connecticut to engage the insurance
industry who have a lot at stake a lot
at stake but the last thing I want to
just end with is something actually for
all of us those of us who don't get to
just strengthen Reggie ourselves and
that is organized we just need to get
organized okay we need a powerful social
movement that's demanding political
change that strengthens the spine of our
elected officials that challenges those
that are standing in the way of progress
and that transforms this whole country
okay and I think every single one of us
can be part of that thank you I didn't
go last to have the last word so I'm
happy to yield back to either Nadine or
Tony you know I think market-based
discipline has a real role to play I
wouldn't call it a carbon tax if you
call it a carbon tax you are not putting
it in the most favorable light I would
put it as the polluter pays the costs of
pollution have to be factored into the
costs of products because right now and
forgive me I've forgotten from my
economics 101 what the economic
efficiency term is maybe you can tell me
where there must be an economist in the
room but essentially internalize the
externality exactly that comes through
it just shows I I need to go back to
school so the the market has to more
accurately reflect the pollution costs
of products number two you know again I
I keep coming back to this point because
I live with it every day but there are
enormous opportunities exciting
opportunities we tend to see climate
change as a great big looming threat but
it's also an opportunity you know
retrofitting those buildings has become
a new industry in many cities the Empire
State Building top to bottom has been
retrofitted and Bill Clinton talks about
this issue every day literally well not
every day but he talks very powerfully
and eloquently about it that this
movement to retrofit our buildings can
be a source of immense job creation
number three and I'll finish on this
point and I said it at the beginning you
know a majority of Americans really get
it that's my sense that they're
concerned about it the question is how
immediate they see the threat as being
and whether economically they see it as
an advantage the more we can talk about
it positively the more we can make those
majority of Americans that majority be
on our side and we do need to organize
when I say we I mean the folks who are
concerned about climate change need to
organize because that majority has been
a silent majority as with anything else
in or a lot of other things in politics
a vocal minority can block action and we
need to make sure that that majority is
less silent and this kind of
conversation as Tony said at the very
beginning is so important as the kind of
step that needs to be taken all around
America maybe not in academic settings
all of them but in the town councils in
the state legislators in the mayoral
offices it needs to come from the bottom
up it's not going to happen in the
Senate this this discussion has been in
terms of error audition way beyond the
normal conversation in Washington DC i
can tell you and it doesn't need to be
this arrow diet or scientifically
informed just as long as it can convey
the basic facts so that grass at the
grassroots level America begins to feel
it's important and that they yes that
they vote that they vote and that they
make this issue a priority thank
so thanks again to our participants I
want to invite on ty Johnson up and then
I'll have a brief announcement right
after that Wow let's give everybody a
round of applause
that was a wonderful wonderful
discussion I hope you all were very
informed educated more it was great to
hear it from a political standpoint it
was funny to hear about the frogs but I
just want to thank Yale University
School of forgery and environmental
studies for putting this event on a
co-sponsoring this event with us and I
just want to recognize just the unsung
heroes we would not be able to have this
event a success without first you guys
being here so give yourselves a round of
applause I'd like to thank I would like
to thank Bethany zimba the assistant
dean like to thank the Sierra Club
Connecticut chapter this here and our
folks that came and travel all the way
far robert gardner came down from dcs
with greenpeace thank you guys very much
um the last question we were asking was
asked what should we do in Connecticut
and what should happen with the
Bridgeport coal plant and just to give
you guys a little bit of knowledge of
what's happening is Connecticut actually
has an opportunity to make history and
become a cold free state and we know
from the discussions that we have that
natural gas is cheaper and it's cleaner
than coal but cold is devastating and it
has horrible impact so Connecticut does
have an opportunity to become cold free
just the other day I seen los angeles
mayor announced that they are going cold
free and this is happening all across
the nation states are starting to become
cold free so Connecticut has a huge
opportunity to continue being a leader
so I want to thank everyone here today
for this discussion Thank You senator
Blumenthal for your time and come in and
talking about this we encourage you to
continue being a leader and D
see but this is what we wanted to do is
to bring this focus and awareness to
President Obama he's been talking about
climate change in his inaugural speech
in the state of the union address on on
februari seventeen fifty thousand
Americans rallied in DC and they were
saying that we need to do something
about this regardless of the science we
know that it's real in bridgeport i live
in Bridgeport we got 30 inches of snow
when Nemo came and we couldn't leave out
of our houses a week later so you know
this stuff is real we really need to do
something about it and now is the time
to do something about it and we will
have a reception afterwards so I
encourage everybody to stick around to
network and get the chance to know each
other please stop by our table and sign
our petition you know stay involved stay
engaged on our website and our melon
list so that you guys can know what's
coming up we have a lot of things coming
up with the Sierra Club and we hope that
you guys can stay engaged if you guys
have to leave we hope that you would
drive home safe stay warm and thank you
have a good night so let me add my
thanks to everyone who made this happen
tonight and especially for all of you to
coming out there are going to be
refreshments and I think dessert sort of
things they're going to be out in in the
Knobloch center there so feel free to
hang around a little bit and thank you
again